look at this story oh my gosh the
disturbing story of the heart attack gun
invented by the cia during the cold war
the heart attack gun fired a dart made
of frozen shellfish toxin that would
enter the target's bloodstream and kill
them in mere minutes without leaving a
trace senator frank church holds aloft
the heart attack gun during a public
hearing i mean think about that a frozen
dart with shellfish toxin that sounds
like caveman technology i mean not
really but it's like based on our
standards like sure you're just
poisoning somebody think about what they
could make what about like polonium in
it or something more brutal
so easily to deliver this stuff
so easy to deliver these kinds of these
kinds of things so there's a scope on it
and they hit you with it you have a
heart attack and it leaves no trace
amazing yep and then what how did that
come out do you know much about this
story yeah because these guys are
testifying in front of congress about it
right they say uh in 1975 more than 30
years of almost unrestricted cia
activity came grinding to a halt before
senator frank church on capitol hill
after the shocking revelations of the
watergate scandal okay so i guess it was
water great the american public had
suddenly gained an intense interest in
the activities of their intelligence
agencies unable to resist the growing
disquiet any longer congress was forced
to peer to the dark corners of the cold
war and some of them held bizarre
secrets
what they found was was the stuff of
paranoid thrillers and hair-raising spy
fiction alike aside from plans to
assassinate national leaders from across
the globe and extensive spying on
american citizens investigators came
across the heart attack gun a macabre
weapon that could cause death in minutes
without leaving a trace this is the
story of what may be one of the most one
of the central intelligence agencies
most chilling gadgets that we know of
yeah there was there was an old
conspiracy where this woman was posting
crazy stuff on facebook
and
people started asking like who was she
and why was she posting this because it
was like seemingly random gibberish it
would be a large paragraph saying
something like i went to the store to
pick up an oatmeal spoon but the dog
came running in with the vanilla when i
saw it i screamed and jumped in the car
and drove to the edge of the cliff where
the surfers were screaming like it was
just nonsense right you were like what
is this and so everyone was trying to
figure out what it was
and i don't know if
it could have just been
fake some people believed that what was
happening was that someone working in
intelligence was using a fake profile to
post messages that someone else could
receive
without anyone making the connection the
message was publicly available hard to
find because it was on a random facebook
profile
and the person only the person who knew
what to look for could read it
others speculated that the woman who was
posting it who was older was former cia
and that she had been drugged with some
kind of psychoactive you know drug to
basically corrupt her mind so that she
could no longer tell people what she
knew like it was someone who knew
secrets was gonna blow the whistle so
they used some kind of drug to twist her
brain so she could no longer form proper
sentences was she c she was cia is that
why that just conspiracy theory just
people were like they believed they
found her name
in like
you know a debate database related to
like government workers or something
could all just be fake could've just
been someone haven't having a laugh but
there was like years of these posts
interesting so it was kind of like i
don't know about that it could just be
some crazy lady who was posting random
gibberish because she was unwell but
it's crazy to hear these stories because
while that story may be just totally
irrelevant
when you hear about in the 70s they have
a heart attack gun my question is
does the united states or any other
government have the ability to make you
insane
how hard would it be
to do something to someone's brain to
make it so they can't talk properly
uh
i don't know if this is off the list of
stuff we can talk about but can you talk
about other of other governments what do
you mean so i uh
i like to research a lot about things
happening in like uh with china's
government yeah and
i've seen some documentaries you're
talking about the havana syndrome and
i've seen some documentaries of people
that um oppose their government and
what happens is that there was this like
one family where
the regime was sent after them and they
had these types of devices that would be
in proximity to their houses and it
would cause them to become very confused
it would make them ill so it's like what
you're describing is sounds kind of
similar and then i also saw something
about how they're working on something
to
uh
essentially something to do with like
controlling their people's brains i
don't know how advanced they are how far
off that is but
uh yeah that's a possibility from what
i've been seeing well this brings me to
yuval noah harari talking about hacking
humans this is like one of the number
two number three guys at the world
economic forum yeah and he's he's
blatantly saying it has come to the
point now where we can hack human brains
and it's going to continue to happen but
but you got to understand that at a
rudiment in a rudimentary sense hacking
human brain is just talking to someone
right you know true right like you know
what to say to make them behave a
certain way so you publish commercials
subliminal messaging was like the oldest
version of this in media you know when
they'd flash an image in the middle of a
commercial and you wouldn't even realize
you saw it but then you start thinking
about it dude when i was uh uh when i
was like 20 i was hanging out with my
friends and we were watching i think i
can remember we might have been watching
like colbert report or something and it
was commercial and it was dumb and it
was just like you know
body armor deodorant we weren't paying
attention and then all of a sudden it
went bam real quick what and i caught it
it said us army go us army what and then
my friend had tivo and so i was like
stop it go back and there was a split
second where it just showed the us army
logo
i don't know what it was let's straight
up from the simpsons yeah join the navy
and then i was like dude for like a
second it just played a bramp and showed
that and flickered in and out and it
said go army like it was like i think it
was go arm it was like it may have been
an army of one whatever the logo was at
the time huh
so i don't i don't know what that was
but it just like flashed on the screen
and so far be it for me to accuse
anybody of doing that on purpose i don't
i don't know
because yeah there are weird mix-ups
with like the commercials that they're
playing it could have been it could have
been because we were watching cable for
sure interesting like like one because
it was called yeah that's right that's
comedy central yeah yeah i saw like uh a
porn one time and they were really in
yeah
it was talking like the russians have
invaded it is a humanitarian crisis just
like wait what i kept repeating it over
and over again recently no this was like
four years ago the russians invaded oh i
don't remember the exact propaganda that
it was saying but it was like seeding
this propaganda over and over again over
the video i was like what the heck weird
it was blatant it wasn't quiet it was
like
it was subtle though it was very weird
very weird the only way to see it was to
listen to it it was crazy huh you got it
so
there are there that might be true it's
going to destroy your brain there are a
couple um interesting devices that we
know about
so apparently you can buy flashlights
that will shine specific patterns of
light or colors that make people feel
nauseated easily done yeah yeah and then
there's um
ulf sound generators which is also the
subject of ultra low yeah ultra low
frequency um i i think
this may be conspiracy
territory like well it's not a
conspiracy it's not criminal but uh the
idea is the military's are working on
technology where and look this up
because this this might be nonsense but
i was reading about ghosts a long time
ago
and i want scientific explanations for
the ghost phenomenon i don't care about
someone being like it's the spirit of
someone i'm like don't get out here and
so what i read was that in many of these
areas where people claim there's
hauntings they've also found evidence of
ultra low frequencies coming from maybe
underground or from from terrestrial
movement things like that like
geological activity
and this can have an impact on someone's
body and cause manipulations and
perception or a sense of someone being
there around them or something like that
right and so this idea was weaponized
purportedly again i haven't read it it
was like 15 years ago i was writing
something on the internet fake but i was
saying something like they have taken
generators that generate ultra low
frequency sound and it causes people to
feel disoriented confused uh paranoid
and sick so these kinds of weapons
i i i would have to say i believe come
on of course militaries around the world
have been working on ways to
incapacitate people by any means
necessary this is the uh from
militarytimes.com it's called talking
plasma you can find that if you look up
militarytimes.com and talking plasma and
uh instead of beaming a flashlight a
flashing light or shouting over a
loudspeaker to keep people away from
sensitive areas new technology being
developed could allow troops to fire a
laser that can form a plasma ball that
talks to the potential intruder what
what talks to someone with a laser okay
this is this is military tech yeah this
is military times.com pentagon
scientists are making talking plasma
laser balls four uses non-lethal weapons
in 2019. that's more like it i was going
to say all these weapons stop or we'll
be forced to fire upon you this is
awesome i think a lot of ufos that we
see on radar are these plasma balls
being moved around really fast just what
were you saying before it was like three
lasers yeah you triangulate at least at
least three three or more by uh
quadrangulate you know you can and then
you you hit a point in the sky and
create a ball of plasma and then you can
move so it's basically all the lasers
are intersecting yeah creating a single
point or the energy intersection you can
see it yeah
crazy
yeah so maybe they're pointing those
towards people's brains i don't know
if they can make their own things
they're gonna
one day ian's gonna be like complaining
of hearing a humming noise
he's gonna be like the panama
the panama pump the panama what was it i
can't remember i wonder what we're
talking about i just i i hear you i mean
all this set aside though i i could
understand them developing these
experimental new technologies to use as
weapons but
they pretty much know how to control
people already you just make them
lazy yeah you just have their ability to
defer gratification
but they've already done it yes but
listen no i mean we're here we've got a
couple of others
there are always going to be some people
in a population who don't fall into it
but if they can if they can
take a
sonar dish or something and point it at
you and click a button and then all of a
sudden you're like no what's happening
yes i love joe biden he's the greatest
president they'd do it they'd be like
all right mission accomplishments i have
to go make biden tunes
you're talking about ways to control
that aren't like um taking away
something like taking away your food or
taking away your money yeah well look as
long as you get people to pursue
pleasure rather than virtue as soon as
they believe that public opinion is on a
specific side of an issue they're going
to go along with it because that's
what's easier for them and they've
habituated themselves towards always
taking the path of least resistance
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there